herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ihr wisst ja max und ich sind
schon verfechter von youtube kacke seit
dem allerersten tag es gibt youtube
karadzic erlassen
die sind ein jahr alt und älter und
mittlerweile schaffst youtube kaká sogar
in die youtube trends das ist richtig
cool anzuschauen jetzt kriegt das
langsam so die anerkennung des auch
verdient insbesondere der gottvater der
youtube kacke mister wm titel schon
gesehen da machen wir heute in youtube
kaka charts oder wenn das heißt wir
versuchen nicht zu lachen und wäre heute
aber lachen muss was eventuell vorkommt
bei youtube kaka bei uns beiden der
krieg kleenex taschentuch ist nicht nur
in seinem mund nicht mehr unsere
richtung schaut die geben unserem
letzten video mein bruder ich kann deine
augen kilos jetzt 38 21
[Musik]
petermann beamter aus es großartig
muss ich wirklich schon soll er sich
selbst unterdrückt dann wollte ich reden
dann kommst raus
ja aber jetzt kaufen jetzt in einem oh
ja mal sehen es nicht aber mein schwanz
ist es ja hat weshalb das sagen wir erst
einmal an ihre frage welche frucht
sondern das in welcher stadt wird die
große liebe folgten kudamm genannt
werden welcher währung bezahlt man auf
hawaii mit alfons gern welches
einheimische tier griff unterirdische
gänge und wird noch diesen meist
ungeliebt und überhaupt warum wir das
tun würden so hart aus
naja das schon mehr gelacht wir wollen
dieses auch mit der antwort ein bisschen
lohne herausgestellt am anfang da ist
gar nicht so lustig aber jetzt gibt es
auch kasten was kommt sprichwörtlich
beim essen was ist damit kostenlos
[Musik]
dabei
rüdiger von welchem land ist bukarest
die hauptstadt
wie geht's weiter in welchem jahr viel
hongkong an die volksrepublik china
zurück
[Musik]
wie nennt man den leiter für
kundenzufriedenheit was ein vorteil
das weiß doch jeder
wer produziert die e klasse so ist
dreimal richtig mich nicht woraus hat
ihr märchen das erste der drei kleinen
schweinchen sein haus gebaut
der war christina welchen sport durch
die 12 ich habe hieß es jetzt kommt und
sagt musikfreunde der sport fußball
ich bin der einzige von allen leuten
schreiben in den kommentaren welcher
sport
[Musik]
so ist die national schlechtes land das
heißt star spangled banner verlor hat
lief wie gespannt wie nicht mich nicht
[Musik]
dort nennen sie einen der beiden monate
in denen steinböcke geburtstag feiern
können
[Musik]
rüdiger klein von irene das und traurig
wenn zwischendurch leute es ist so es
kommt einfach immer so rüdiger kommt
immer trockene
das war jetzt mal kleiner ausschnitt aus
dem video leute wohl auch nicht zu viel
davon zeigen können sich gerne anschauen
liegt sie aber in der beschreibung hier
um bekommt ihr persönlich vorgestellt
das video hier könnt ihr natürlich main
kanal abonnieren und hier gehts zur
neuesten folge von wasser das geht da
waren wir selbst alten kelter wegs und
haben das spiel mit den leuten die
athleten ja oder auch tabu
[Musik]